for most americans higher prices are
making it harder to afford basic
necessities the annual inflation rate is
at a 40-year high hitting 7.9 percent in
february housing costs have increased
nearly 5 percent the biggest yearly jump
since 1991 nancy chen visited south
florida where rent increases are the
highest in the nation
so what's the first one what's this one
called just about every renter in south
florida has the same story when the
release comes up sticker shock that's
what happened to jamie wolfe a single
mom raising three kids
we're looking at almost a thousand
dollars in an increase before previously
i got you know five percent six percent
i think increases things that you could
kind of prepare for sure but a thousand
dollars it's impossible to prepare for
nationwide rents have soared nearly 20
percent year over year but in south
florida they're up nearly 50 percent
you think this is going to get worse
there's no question there's no question
in our mind diana stanley runs the
lord's place in west palm beach which
helps homeless people and those on the
brink she says that calls seeking help
have doubled in the past year we are
going to have a massive increase in
homelessness betty rivers is hoping to
afford any type of shelter after her
rent rose from 900 to 15 hundred dollars
a month it was a downfall for me for now
this grandmother of five is sleeping on
her daughter's couch if i give up then i
feel like i'm giving up on myself
the end may not be in sight florida has
no rent control and demand is far
greater than supply with more people
moving there during the pandemic the
costs stanley says will keep going up
pricing many more out of the market i
just want to be prepared beyond this
year you know i just want to have a
little bit of a little bit of security
for cbs mornings i'm michi chen